nevermind stormy Daniels I am frankly
sick of all this tabloid crap let's get
to what's important so everyone's fired
up about this 1.3 trillion dollar
omnibus spending bill including some of
the president's biggest supporters and
cool to our guests last week tweeted
congratulations president Schumer Rush
Limbaugh said I'm feeling like I just
saw Donald Trump get on the escalator
and go back up and our other guest from
last Sunday judge Jeanine what she
argued that this is all on Congress not
the president so here's what I think in
my piece on Fox News calm this weekend I
talked about the Rio cmoocs Schumer
budget that's because we now know for
sure that none of our leaders in
Congress are interested in either
implementing what the American people
vote for in elections or solving our
massive debt crisis they really are as
bad as each other
and that's the main driver of the
populist revolution on the left with
Bernie Sanders and the right with Donald
Trump it's the belief that it doesn't
matter who you vote for nothing ever
changes and Congress proved that again
this week with this swamp budget the
president defends it because of extra
money for the military but you know
where most of that's going to end up
don't you in the pockets of the military
industrial swamp that's why the stock
prices of defense contractors soared on
Friday there was no effort to curb the
corruption that wastes so much money in
the defense budget in health care right
across government and frankly there seem
to be no effort from the White House to
shake all this up which was the whole
point of Donald Trump yes we need a
disrupter but we need a disrupter who
knows what they're doing the truth is
none of this will ever change until we
do one big thing decentralized power
from the federal government to the
states from the states to towns and
counties and cities and then further to
local communities neighborhoods and
individuals that is positive populism
and it depends on two things happening a
president who truly wants and knows how
to dismantle the power structure in
Washington and electing new disruptive
members of Congress in 2018 2020 and
beyond who are really committed to
returning power to the people
is the next revolution we need now I
really want to know what you think
especially about the president's
handling of all this so please let me
know I read all your comments and I
can't reply to everyone but I really
want to know what you think so follow us
at Steve Hilton X and at next Rev FNC